hey what's up you guys I'm Tiffany Smith
from fandango movie clips and the first
panel of Star Wars Celebration just
ended the JJ Abrams Kathleen Kennedy won
and it was amazing um not only did they
talk about the movie but we also saw the
trailer and all of the fans were so
excited for it myself included but
before we get to your guys reactions I
want to take us back to this morning
where fans were lined up for over 24
hours to get into this room so let's see
what they had to say what's your name
Anakin is it really yeah I mean please
let me see your ID I have a school ID
4th celebrations are bored I'm assuming
that you got here pretty early 930 I'm
30 morning
Oh
so you just walked out of seeing the
trailer what's your one word reaction no
words
not enough stormtroopers I know right
excitement is pure excitement nostalgia
i cried i started crying also it's just
from the packet i saw it when I was 11
happy tears like the happiest of happy
tears ever hear the music again Andrew
Lippa overweight and like tears coming
down I'm just I can't wait it's gonna be
off awesome dad yeah I just the whole
beginning shop with the whole sepia tone
jewelry bb-8 I was surprised to see
Harrison Ford I you know what's not
expecting he would show up this soon
chrome trooper look crazy and that cloud
trooper with the Cape the reveal of the
starters for the way that JJ yeah does
something hey guess what guess I'll look
at lose your mind aren't you guys will
make sure you keep your eyes on fandango
movie clips because we are going to be
covering all of Star Wars Celebration
and make sure you check out that trailer
because that's what I'm gonna be doing
on every break that I get on my song on
my iPad on my computer wherever I can
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below I'm Tiffany Smith